thanks very much for joining uh adam so
adam is here today to speak to both us
about his work on
nlp uh in the particular application of
south africa's kobe 19 what's up hotline
uh sounds really interesting
adam i have no bio for you so i can't
make a informed introduction so i'll
allow you then to
go ahead and introduce yourself please
thanks everyone for joining in thank you
for
uh
moderating the site i don't think you
have a name tag here but thank you
anyway
hi so i'm adam chang i'm a data
scientist at id insight um based into
car senegal and i'll explain more about
that in a bit
but
this talk just centers on work we've
done
with a covet hotline in south africa and
answering people's questions um
so
brief overview of the talk um i'll just
start introducing
the organizations and platforms involved
some of them are pretty nifty like
innovative things in the developing
world
then we'll talk about like possible
machine learning solutions in this
context and related to this problem
i'll give a more detailed overview of
what model we're using and how we built
out a solution
[Music]
then after that we'll talk about like uh
two kind of sidebar things related to
our model one is like how do you
contextualize something um that's you
know largely been developed uh in the
global north by americans to work in a
different context
and also um how do you maximize
efficiency and like minimize computation
time when resources are scarce
and that's about it so
id insight which is the organization i
work for um we're around 200 people
worldwide um been around for like 10
years now
one of my managers always likes to joke
but not really joke that we're always
building the plane as we're flying um
but essentially we have a
traditional business of like working on
evaluations and
monitoring with governments and ngos but
now we have a growing data science and
engineering arm um we're around like 10
to 15 people now
but hiring rapidly so there's a link
there
um and we're partnered with an
organization called breakout.org so they
do mobile health technology
um largely based in south african
operating worldwide and i have a blurb
from them that i've been asked to read
so
precalculus.org is a south african
non-profit organization that has been
using mobile technology to improve
health and health systems since 2007
using simple communications such as sms
ussd and ip messaging specifically
whatsapp precode.org approach harnesses
the power of communication between
citizens health workers and the health
system to ensure that one citizens are
informed and empowered two health
workers are supported and valued in
three health system officials have the
information they need to make informed
and effective decisions to improve
service delivery and quality
um
so
back in 2014 south africa's national
department of health in praeko
introduced a
mobile service called mom connect um so
this essentially was like a two-way
connection between expectant mothers and
health officials
to like essentially maximize like
people's success and information they
had during pregnancy um
the blurb i have from prank out for that
is
mom connect is the national department
of health in south africa's national
mobile maternal messaging program where
mothers attending their fourth antenatal
visit in any public health facility in
the country can sign up to receive
stage-based messaging to help them care
for themselves and their baby through
pregnancy and up until the baby is two
years old
additionally mothers have access to a
text-based help desk where they can ask
questions and get responses directly
from the ndoh launched in 2014 the
program was the first national scale
program of its kind and has enrolled
over 4 million mothers which represents
between 70 and 80 of the mothers giving
birth in the public health system for
this period
so nowadays when you hear about like
innovations like this um they seem
pretty like front of the mill but this
was you know all the way back in 2014
and it was like
it's a pretty nifty way to connect his
citizens with the government so that was
launched by south africa's national
department of health and precalc
and then this year in march 2020 as you
know what hit um
these partnered organizations also
launched something called health connect
for
cobit so the blurb this is the last verb
uh the blurb i have from that is in
march 2020 praykout.org realized that
the health connect approach could be
rapidly deployed to address many aspects
of the challenges faced by organizations
and governments worldwide related to
cobit 19.
health connect for coven 19 was
initially launched in south africa as an
informational whatsapp service for the
national department of health and
quickly attracted the interests of other
countries and organizations resulting in
similar instances of the service being
launched before the world health
organization 10 other governments and
two additional public health
organizations within a few months
these services have now reached over 26
million citizens and health workers with
over 650 million critical covenant
messages in 26
languages okay awesome um
so
essentially mom connect and health
connect for covid are these two
health information based services that
operate over whatsapp and are like
pretty freely accessible to all citizens
these are useful and important programs
like tens of millions of people in you
know a bunch of countries and 26
languages use these programs
but they're very menu driven and menu
dependent
so if you were to have tried the
covid connect service the health connect
for covid
um before id insight in breakout worked
on this
it was very much like a phone tree where
like
you could select from a list of options
whether it's like prevention symptoms or
treatment
um
you know you type like prevention for
prevention or you type like eight for
like symptoms or something and then you
get like another menu and you can access
information that way
but it's pretty traditional like a phone
tree almost and
it's not like super responsive or
intuitive for citizens to use
we in partnership with praeko thought
that machine learning could come into
this picture
we want users to interact naturally with
these services
and ask their own questions
and that like
just lets people
get information completely relevant to
what they want to know without having to
navigate a phone treat it's also
important because it gives health
authorities a lot better insight into
what people are actually wondering about
right like
trends and topics with covid and like
vaccines change overnight almost um
and health authorities this way can like
get inside on what people are asking
about so they can you know edit the faqs
that are in this service but they can
even change like offline messaging like
if everyone's suddenly scared about
microchips like maybe they need to
launch some like tv campaigns
the problem with this is that user
question volume is much greater than
human answering capability by some of
the usage numbers i shared previously
so
here's where machine learning comes into
the picture
chat bots aren't a new thing but
this can't really be any old chatbot
like i don't know here like every bank's
like mobile application has a chatbot
even like most of the banks here in
senegal have a chat bot on their mobile
application
but you need to be very careful with
chatbots right because misinformation
and distrust are very rampant in our
context like this is a combination of
covin vaccines like really global
terrible like vaccine inequality like
things that are sent over whatsapp
and because this is a partnership with
the government in the national
department of health it's really
critical that accuracy is fully there
so
this is hugging faces transformers which
is a well-known like library that works
with um
a lot of the fancy nlp technology like
burt noma and gpt and like if you try to
ask it a question like did bill gates
put microchips in vaccines um
the answers can really like get you all
over the place right like
nobody mentioned monsanto what does
monsanto have to do with this
um
but basically a demonstration that you
can't just like throw this at some
off-the-shelf model
so here we don't particularly want
anything fancy
we have pretty limited resources to
handle
millions of users um it's really
critical that we avoid wrong information
and all of this needs to be like
explainable to like government and civil
society stakeholders who like don't know
what bert is
um basically we need something quite
supervised which like nlp models
generally aren't
um any questions so far from anyone
about
the context or the setup of this problem
um you can type it in the chat or the q
a
and feel free to ask questions
yeah please feel free to raise hands
also
okay awesome i'll keep going but please
ask questions um i know that
i often i'm not clear and go too fast
uh cool so
starting from fundamentals here of like
how you build this kind of system
it's pretty clear that like your
solution needs to center on a bank of
faqs like that's the only way that you
ensure
information that goes out is accurate
right like you need
a pool of accurate information and
that's the only thing you send out
um so
right like even if it's not fully
accurate relevant to what a user is
asking for at least you're not sending
out like fake news um so this is like a
very supervised aspect of our model
and this this makes your like
model design and model choice a lot
simpler because now it's just like you
need to match user questions to the bank
of faqs that you have like maybe you
have you know three faqs about pregnancy
a couple faqs about like microchips and
stuff
and you like you get a question comes in
like how do you match it
um you can try doing things in a
traditional like train a model kind of
manner right you like fit engrams to a
bunch of training data and user
questions you can build like
sparse tf idf matrices you select
features you fit some classifiers or
like
you know something like this table i you
know you just directly ingest into
pandas and like call like you know two
functions and like uh an otk like
whatever
um but there's some significant problems
with that approach
one is that you have no training data
here like
even if you could source it like
covid changes really quickly like
basically overnight and these topics
like
like come out of nowhere um
so you have no training data even if you
have training data like that training is
all but useless like a month from now
the other thing is that your faq bank
needs to evolve over time so you're
gonna have faqs added right like as soon
as some rumor comes out about george
soros like you need some epic news about
him
um you're going to have faqs that are
removed when like people are no longer
asking about something
you know like a beta variant
when did anyone last ask about the beta
variant um
some ipqs are going to be like split
some are modified and like
essentially you like
you can't really train like
some classifier you know like one
against many or whatever that predicts
like
faq c1 given q and faq cn given q
because you know you need to put in like
n plus one you need to put in plus two
and you're gonna alter like all the uh
relevant parts of your faq
so even if you like use bert in like
this manner where you try to fit a
traditional supervised predictive model
like it just won't work
um
so
any questions there or any anyone want
to suggest maybe like guess at the
approach that we did show us here nlp
knowledge
[Music]
i have one question myself oh sorry we
have some questions here in the chat
i wasn't monitoring very closely
um so ben has asked maybe it's a dumb
question is the analysis done only on
each text or the string of responses and
what people said earlier
that's that's a great question
and you would probably want to do the
second one right because that gives you
as much
information as possible
um
but that's that's not what we do
necessarily that's what we're adapting
towards and i'll explain that in a bit
um
similarity between user question and
bank uh
seated topic models um so no seated
topic models here
just because like
if you
need to adjust a hierarchical model um
of that nature like
you need a data scientist essentially
like
always working on this problem when like
new faqs are going to be added to top
exchange which like doesn't really make
for a super sustainable long-run
solution
um and then here is a
similarity between user question in the
faq bank yeah exactly so
we basically only want to rely on the
user question and then the themes of
each faq um
and this is what word embeddings are
incredibly useful for so
i'm sure most of you know what this is
but
word embeddings have become this like
you know like
the the center of nlp over the past 10
years or so um
basically where you can project each
word into a vocab and a vocabulary into
some like in-dimensional space so here
everything is on a 2d grid but usually
it's like
you know like a 100 or 300 or more
dimensions
and words that are related to each other
will be closer together and you'll see
some pretty cool relations right where
like
uh paris is to france as london is to
england like if you do the vector
subtraction or something um but
basically this really helps with uh our
problem because like
if you have an f
q that's about france
um but like suddenly like the rumors
change overnight and now it's like
england putting microchips into the
vaccine or something like this model
will still detect that these topics are
similar or like if people are asking
like are there microchips in vaccines in
paris like this model still gets that so
word embeddings are pretty useful here
you can start with the basics and that's
what we do
essentially for each faq in our bank we
just assign it relevant tags that need
to match a user query um and this is
done with like
trained content moderators we've built
out some tools for this also but like if
you get an faq like
is it safe to get the vaccine when
pregnant then maybe you tag it with
pregnant vaccine and safe so that
the user question comes in and it
relates to all three of those tags more
or less than like
it seems like you should send out that
faq
so this is an overview of
what that looks like um
you see this incoming message comes in
that's like asking uh you know
uh the person's expecting and they're
expecting a child uh and they're
wondering if it's safe to get vaccinated
the first faq might be about like bill
gates put a microchip in the vaccine or
something but like it would be tagged
with those and that doesn't match
anything the second faq might be just
about like vaccine and pregnant
um
and since this question has a lot to do
with vaccine and pregnant even though it
doesn't have like
exact word matches by any means
it would score highly and it would be
sent out
uh
maybe you have a final faq that's about
like vaccine and side effects or
something but uh the tags wouldn't match
so
essentially like this you can calculate
a score for each faq in your bank
and then send out like what's most
relevant
adam i'll just point out that we have uh
three minutes left uh in in your time
sorry is it three minutes or 13 minutes
i'm so sorry yes
indeed it is 13 minutes disregard please
no worries um
so just some sidebars on the model
which we've thought are i thought are
pretty interesting um
one is contextualization so
when you build these kinds of embeddings
um they're always pre-trained and uh
trained on like very large corpuses of
text so in our case we're using the
standard like google news uh
word to vec model like
skip grams like negative sampling all
that
um
what that means though is that like
the context that our model is being
deployed in and works in is pretty
different than where it was trained
right so like
these are informal messages sent by
south african citizens to like a
whatsapp hotline right like nobody's
gonna type out like very formal
questions because it's what's up
but our training data comes from like
news headlines
from the us and europe uh
and like you can just imagine how
everything differs between these
contexts
so um
there are four main things maybe you
need to be careful about one is like
misspellings and typos and like even
regional english differences like people
are typing on phone keyboards um
you also need to be careful about like
poor grammar and syntax because that
differs uh text shorthand and finally
like regional phrases and slang right
like uh apparently if you say jab and
like a lot of the
english speaking world that means
vaccine but like as an american i have
no idea what that means
um
so
first thing misspellings and typos um
what happens when people misspell
messages that are sent to this hotline
it's a very easy problem to detect what
uh words are misspelled um
like there are very traditional
libraries for this including [ __ ] spell
and you can even find like
what uh alternative spellings you know
the user might have meant right that's
just like edit distance
um
but it's a much harder problem to
determine like which is the correct word
that you use right so like
here if the user spells like p-a-i-n-e
like
a human would look at this and be like
oh they're asking about vaccines like it
should be pain but like how do you train
a model to like you know look at all of
these and say oh is it t-pain no it's
pierre
um
but this is again somewhere where you
can use the context and embeddings so
like
we have a pretty known context of like
covid vaccines and like specifically all
the faqs related to that and like
we'll have vectors for all of those
words and you know out of all of these
suggestions raised by the huntsville
library you can like find ones that are
most similar to
um the actual context and like
embeddings in the faqs and
essentially we did some experiments with
this where like
we artificially added errors to um
possible user queries so like if you
look here like
this is a error rate of like .07 on each
character and like these messages are
pretty jungle right like most people
would be more careful than this
even over whatsapp uh
the graph on the right um essentially
you want to compare between the solid
line of a color and the dotted line of
the color so dotted line is shows
degraded performance as there's more
typos
um like as error rate on each character
goes up on the x-axis
but um solid line is using the like
misspelling correction that we're doing
just like contextualized spell check and
like you can see that performance like
barely goes down even when there are a
lot of typos which is pretty amazing
um
other things you want to worry about
poor grammar and syntax uh
how do you fix this
you actually don't care about programmer
and syntax because when you deal with
embeddings um you're only looking at
like
words and like engrams at best um
especially static embeddings this is
different if you're doing something with
like where uh embeddings are
contextualized but here like
the grammar and the syntax doesn't
matter as long as the words are there
which is like a you know it's a
simplifying thing but it's a feature for
us
uh other things you want to worry about
uh
text shorthand and regional phrases and
slang so what's a jab what's a laity um
here you can
pretty much just use a glossary because
like some of these things are so
specific in the context that like you
know that if somebody someone's jabbed
like a whatsapp hotline about copic they
probably need vaccine you know if
somebody sends the word shot to a
whatsapp hotline about kovid like
you'd hope they'd be a vaccine right
like
um so even shot you can say like oh
they're probably vaccine um
even something like cobit because our uh
training data largely came from you know
just like google news stuff in like 2013
and 2014 um
code is nowhere in that data set but you
can like put it as a linear combination
of other
embeddings so here like virus and
pandemic and like turns out that works
good enough right because you're just
looking at like where things sit in the
in dimensional space like the 300
dimensional space
um any questions so far yes there's uh
one from leave she's asking
ari the user questions to faq matching
are you matching sentence embeddings to
faq tag embeddings or are you doing some
ner or tag extraction from the user's
questions first and then matching to the
faq terms
great question um and this is something
i was not specific about
we are not matching sentence embeddings
um
i don't know if you've tried to use
sentence embeddings but like at least in
genesis like
like doctorvec
library it's
the sentence embedding quality is much
lower than the wording that inequality
let's say
um so no we don't capture embeddings for
each sentence
what we do is uh somewhat clever where
like for each sentence we extract the
words that are likely going to be
most relevant to
each faq so like
let me try to go back a few slides and
share this um
here
we
uh
when we want to compare the similarity
to like the vaccine tag for example
we're going to take the like top 10
percent of this message that's most
similar to vaccine or something so it's
like uh
you can think about it as like you have
uh two groups of like end points in like
50 or 100 or 300 dimensional space right
like how do you like match like uh these
points to each other right they're like
giant like clusters essentially right
you you can't do like it's it's very
hard to try to like project these two
groups of points into something else and
then like check the distance but like
you can just compare the closest points
within the cluster right and i think if
you were to do this like intuitively on
paper you would do that
um cool i'm just going to try to finish
this presentation really quickly
and then
take some more questions so
lastly some speed improvements um
we did this at first and uh it could
handle like eight requests per second um
which
you know
didn't really fascinate but
since millions of people use this
service that was unacceptable to our
partners um so we did some profiling
and if you run this like
function if you run our like a matching
algorithm like 400 times it takes like
40 seconds but then you notice that like
two functions pretty much dominate all
of this so one is a check array and
sklearn
takes 22 seconds so over half
and then uh another function called
assert all finite takes like 10 seconds
um so these combined take up like 80 90
of the time that's being uh used for
your function calls
um
and like
it really doesn't sound like you need to
like check arrays right like what does
check array do it just does input
validation um and a certain finite does
the same thing but we know that like
we're feeding in valid uh
vectors because we you know we train
these uh we we're guaranteed that
they're like perfect size vectors now
and they're all finite anyway so uh
what do you do when you have something
like this and you want to speed it up
well you take out skit learn
the only reason we used sklearn was to
do some like linear algebra cosine
similarity here um but
since everything here is like just a dot
product you can just use mp dot
um right and then like
i guess the math should take the same
amount of time uh but
it should take much less time to do
input validation because we're pretty
sure the inputs are safe
um
turns out you can go one step further
in cosine similarity uh you have like
this denominator term that's there to
normalize all of the uh
vectors um
right because if you have like two
things that are like really far out they
don't have a much larger dot product
regardless of like you know like if
there are two things that are short and
have the same angle like that that will
have a much lesser dot product and you
want those to equal because you only
care about the angle
um
but you'll notice that you have to do
three dot products to do the
normalization better yet you can just
pre-normalize all of the
word vectors embeddings beforehand and
now you only need to do a single call to
mpdot so if you do all of this then it
gets to 100 requests per second which is
good enough for now um on a single ec2
server
uh
yeah that's it um
some results and next steps um
based on early benchmarking
of user queries that could be answered
by the faq bank
over 70 are successfully matched
the downside there is that a lot of user
queries are about topics not covered by
the faqs so what that means is we're
building out more real-time monitoring
of the message stream and our partners
at pracal are working on adapting the
faq bank
in more real time
um other things we're looking at are
training and sourcing language amendings
in other languages this breakout works
in over 26 languages
finally model calibration i saw there
was a question about feedback that ben
answered but
right now
we do collect feedback from users on how
well this answered their question uh but
more than that i think we want a layer
where like you just have latent
estimates that change over time of like
how popular uh each faq is and how
accurate it is when we send it out um
cool uh that's all from me big thank you
to everyone
especially to
the hosts of pi data and people who are
listening as well as
are collaborators at pray count and id
insight
this work i am required to say is funded
by the global innovation fund very
generously
great thank you very much adam there's a
couple more questions in the q a but i
think we're a bit out of time there so
maybe if you guys could um pass us along
via slack
uh that would be excellent
okay awesome okay thank you thank you
adam